a portion of this video was sponsored by
lastpass
this video is about a pattern people
thought was impossible
and a material that wasn't supposed to
exist
the story begins over 400 years ago
in prague i'm now in prague and the
czech republic which is perhaps my
favorite european city that i've visited
so far
i'm going to visit the kepler museum
because he's one of the most famous
scientists who lived and worked around
prague
i want to tell you five things about
johannes kepler
that are essential to our story
number one kepler is most famous for
figuring out that the shapes of
planetary orbits are
ellipses but before he came to this
realization
he invented a model of the solar system
in which the planets were on nested
spheres
separated by the platonic solids
what are the platonic solids well they
are objects where
all of the faces are identical and all
of the vertices
are identical which means you can rotate
them through some
angle and they look the same as they did
before
so the cube is an obvious example then
you also have
the tetrahedron the octahedron
the dodecahedron which has 12 pentagonal
sides
and the icosahedron which has 20 sides
and that's it there are just five
platonic solids
which was convenient for kepler because
in his day they only knew
about six planets so this allowed him to
put a unique platonic solid between
each of the planetary spheres
essentially he used them as spacers
he carefully selected the order of the
platonic solids
so that the distances between planets
would match astronomical observations as
closely as possible
he had this deep abiding belief that
there was some geometric regularity in
the universe
and of course there is just not this
two kepler's attraction to geometry
extended to more practical questions
like
how do you stack cannonballs so they
take up the least space on a ship's deck
by 1611 kepler had an answer hexagonal
close packing
and the face centered cubic arrangement
are both equivalently
and optimally efficient with cannonballs
occupying about 74 percent of the volume
they take up
now this might seem like the obvious way
to stack spheres i mean it is the way
that oranges
are stacked in the supermarket but
kepler hadn't proved it he just
stated it as fact which is why this
became known as kepler's conjecture
now it turns out he was right but it
took around
400 years to prove it the formal proof
was only published in the journal form
of mathematics
in 2017. three
kepler published his conjecture in a
pamphlet called deniva sexangula
on the six cornered snowflake in which
he wondered
there must be a definite cause why
whenever snow begins to fall
its initial formations invariably
display the shape of a six cornered
starlet
for if it happens by chance why do they
not fall just as well with five corners
or with seven
why always with six in kepler's day
there was no real theory of atoms or
molecules or how they self-arrange into
crystals
but kepler seemed to be on the verge of
understanding this
i mean he speculates about the smallest
natural unit of a liquid like water
essentially a water molecule and how
these tiny units could
stack together mechanically to form the
hexagonal crystal
not unlike the hexagonal close-packed
cannonballs
four kepler knew that regular hexagons
can cover a flat surface perfectly with
no gaps in mathematical jargon we say
the hexagon tiles the plane
periodically you know that a tiling is
periodic
if you can duplicate a portion of it and
continue the pattern only through
translation
with no rotations or reflections
periodic tilings can also have
rotational symmetry
a rhombus pattern has twofold symmetry
because if you rotate it 180 degrees one
half turn
the pattern looks the same as it did
before equilateral triangles have
three-fold symmetry
squares have four-fold symmetry and
hexagons have six-fold symmetry but
those
are the only symmetries you can have two
three four and six there is
no fivefold symmetry regular pentagons
do not tile the plane but that didn't
stop kepler from trying
see this pattern right here he published
it in his book harmonics mundi or
harmony of the world it has a certain
five-fold symmetry
but not exactly and it's not entirely
clear
how you would continue this pattern to
tile the whole plane
there are an infinite number of shapes
that can tile the plane periodically
the regular hexagon can only tile the
plane periodically
there are also an infinite number of
shapes that can tile the plane
periodically
or non-periodically for example
isosceles triangles can tile the plane
periodically
but if you rotate a pair of triangles
well then the pattern is no longer
perfectly periodic
a sphinx tile can join with another
rotate it at 180 degrees
and tile the plane periodically but a
different arrangement of these
same tiles is non-periodic
this raises the question are there some
tiles that can
only tile the plane non-periodically
well in 1961 how wang was studying
multi-colored square tiles the rules
were
touching edges must be the same color
and you can't rotate or reflect tiles
only slide them around now the question
was
if you're given a set of these tiles can
you tell
if they will tile the plane wang's
conjecture
was that if they can tile the plane well
they can do so periodically
but it turned out wang's conjecture was
false
his student robert berger found a set of
20
426 tiles that could tile the plane
but only non-periodically
think about that for a second here we
have a finite set of tiles okay it's a
large number
but it's finite and it can tile all the
way out to infinity
without ever repeating the same pattern
there's no way even to force them to
tile periodically
and a set of tiles like this that can
only tile the plane
non-periodically is called an aperiodic
tiling
and mathematicians wanted to know were
there aperiodic tilings that required
fewer tiles well robert berger himself
found a set with only 104 donald knuth
got the number down to 92
and then in 1969 you had raphael
robinson who came up with
six tiles just six that could tile the
entire plane without ever repeating
then along came roger penrose who would
ultimately get the number down to two
penrose started with a pentagon he added
other pentagons around it
and of course noticed the gaps but this
new shape
could fit within a larger pentagon which
gave penrose an idea what if he took the
original pentagons
and broke them into smaller pentagons
well now some of the gaps start
connecting up into
rhombus shapes other gaps have three
spikes
but penrose didn't stop there he
subdivided the pentagons again
now some of the gaps are large enough
that you can use pentagons to fill in
part of them
and the remaining holes you're left with
are just rhombuses
stars and a fraction of a star that
penrose calls a justice cap
you can keep subdividing indefinitely
and you will only ever find
these shapes so with just these pieces
you can tile the plane
aperiodically with an almost five-fold
symmetry
the fifth thing about johannes kepler is
that if you take his pentagon pattern
and you overlay it on top of penrose's
the two match up perfectly
[Music]
once penrose had his pattern he found
ways to simplify the tiles
he distilled the geometry down to just
two tiles a thick rhombus
and a thin rhombus the rules for how
they can come together can be enforced
by bumps and notches
or by matching colors and the rules
ensure that these
two single tiles can only tile the plane
non-periodically
just two tiles go all the way out to
infinity without
ever repeating now one way to see this
is to print up two copies of the same
penrose pattern
and one on a transparency and overlay
them on top of each other
now the resulting interference you get
is called a moire
pattern where it is dark the patterns
are
not aligned you can see there are
also some light spots and that's where
the patterns do
match up and as i rotate around you can
see the
light spots move in and get smaller and
then at a certain point
they move out and get bigger
and what i want to do is try to enlarge
one of these bright spots
and see how big of a matching section i
can find
oh yes yes it's like
all of a sudden everything is
illuminated i love it
so these patterns are perfectly matching
up here here here here and here but
not along these radial lines
and that is why they look dark so what
this shows us
is that you can't ever match any section
perfectly to one
beneath it there will always be some
difference
so my favorite penrose pattern is
actually made out of
these two shapes which are called kites
and darts and they have these very
particular angles
and the way they're meant to match up is
based on these two curves you can see
there's a curve on each piece
and so you have to connect them so that
the curves are continuous
and that's the rule that allows you to
build an aperiodic tiling from these two
pieces
so uh i laser cut thousands
of these pieces and oh i'm gonna
try to put them together and make a huge
penrose oh man
come on
if you stare at a pattern of kites and
darts you'll start to notice all kinds
of
regularities like stars and suns
but look closer and they don't quite
repeat in the way you'd expect them to
these two tiles create an ever-changing
pattern that extends out to infinity
without repeating does this mean
there is only one pattern of kites and
darts
and every picture that we see is just a
portion
of that overall singular pattern
well the answer is no there are actually
an uncountably infinite number of
different patterns of kites and darts
that tile the entire plane
and it gets weirder if you were on any
of those tilings
you wouldn't be able to tell which one
it is
i mean you might try to look further and
further out gather more and more data
but
it's futile because any finite region
of one of these tilings appears
infinitely many times
in all of the other versions of those
tilings
i mean don't get me wrong those tilings
are also different in
an infinite number of ways but it's
impossible to tell that unless you could
see the whole pattern
which is impossible
there's this kind of paradox to penrose
tilings
where there's an uncountable infinity
of different versions but just by
looking at them
you could never tell them apart
now what if we count up all the kites
and darts in this pattern
well i get 440 kites and 272
darts does that ratio ring any bells
well if you divide one by the other you
get 1.618
that is the golden ratio
so why does the golden ratio appear in
this pattern
well as you know it contains a kind of
five-fold symmetry
and of all the irrational constants the
golden ratio
phi is the most five-ish of the
constants i mean you can express the
golden ratio as
0.5 plus 5 to the power of 0.5
times 0.5 the golden ratio is also
heavily associated with pentagons
i mean the ratio of the diagonal to an
edge
is the golden ratio and the kite and
dart pieces themselves
are actually sections of pentagons same
with the rhombuses
so they actually have the golden ratio
built right
into their construction the fact that
the ratio of kites to darts approaches
the golden ratio an irrational number
provides evidence that the pattern can't
possibly be periodic
if the pattern were periodic then the
ratio of kites to darts
could be expressed as a ratio of two
whole numbers
the number of kites to darts in each
periodic segment
and it goes deeper if you draw on the
tiles
not curves but these particular straight
lines
well now when you put the pattern
together you see something interesting
they all connect up perfectly into
straight lines
there are five sets of parallel lines
this is a kind of proof of the five-fold
symmetry of the pattern
but it is not perfectly regular
take a look at any one set of parallel
lines you'll notice
there are two different spacings call
them long and short
from the bottom we have long short long
short long
long wait that breaks the pattern
these gaps don't follow a periodic
pattern either
but count up the number of longs and
shorts in any section
here i get 13 shorts and 21 longs
and you have the fibonacci sequence
1 1 2 3 5 8 13 21
34 and so on and the ratio of
one fibonacci number to the previous one
approaches
the golden ratio
now the question penrose faced from
other scientists was
could there be a physical analog for
these patterns
do they occur in nature perhaps in
crystal structure
penrose thought that was unlikely the
very nature of a crystal is that it is
made up of repeating units
just as the fundamental symmetries of
the shapes that tile the plane had been
worked out much
earlier the basic unit cells that
compose
all crystals were well established there
are 14 of them
and no one had ever seen a crystal that
failed to fit
one of these patterns and there was
another problem
crystals are built by putting atoms and
molecules together
locally whereas penrose tilings well
they seem to require some sort of
long range coordination take this
pattern for example
you could put a dart over here
and continue to tile out to infinity no
problems
or you could put a kite
over here on the other side again no
problems
but if you place the kite
and dart in here simultaneously
well then this pattern will not work
i mean you can keep tiling for a while
but when you get to somewhere around
here
well it's not gonna work you can put a
dart in there which completes the
pattern nicely but then you get this
really awkward shape there which is
actually the shape of another dart
but if you put that one in there then
the
lines don't match up the pattern doesn't
work so how could this work as a crystal
i mean both of these tiles obey the
local rules
but in the long term they just don't
work in the early 1980s
paul steinhardt and his students were
using computers to model how atoms come
together into condensed matter
that is essentially solid material at
the smallest scales
and he found that locally they like to
form icosahedrons
but this was known to be the most
forbidden shape because it is full
of five-fold symmetries so the question
they posed was
how big can these zykosahedrons get they
thought maybe 10 atoms or
100 atoms but inspired by penrose
tilings
they designed a new kind of structure a
3d analog of penrose tilings now known
as a quasi-crystal
and they simulated how x-rays would
diffract off such a structure
and they found a pattern with rings of
10 points reflecting the five-fold
symmetry
just a few hundred kilometers away
completely unaware of their work another
scientist dan
schechtman created this flaky material
from
aluminum and manganese and when he
scattered electrons off his material
this is the picture he got it
almost perfectly matches the one made by
steinhardt
so if penrose tilings require long
range coordination then how do you
possibly make
quasi crystals well i was talking to
paul steinhardt about this and he told
me
if you just use the matching rules on
the edges
those rules are not strong enough and if
you apply them locally you run into
problems like this you misplace
tiles but he said if you have rules for
the vertices the way the vertices can
connect with each other those rules are
strong enough
locally so that you never make a mistake
and the pattern
can go on to infinity one of the seminal
papers on quasi crystals
was called deniva quinquangula
on the pentagonal snowflake in a shout
out
to kepler now not everyone was delighted
at the announcement of quasi crystals a
material that up until then people
thought
totally defied the laws of nature double
nobel prize winner
linus pauling famously remarked there
are no quasi crystals
only quasi scientists
but uh schechtman got the last laugh he
was awarded the nobel prize for
chemistry in 2011
and quasi crystals have since been grown
with beautiful dodecahedral shapes
they are currently being explored for
applications from
non-stick electrical insulation and
cookware to
ultra durable steel and the thing about
this whole story that fascinates me the
most
is what exists that we just can't
perceive because it's considered
impossible
i mean the symmetries of regular
geometric shapes seemed
so obvious and certain that no one
thought to look beyond them
that is until penrose and what we found
are
patterns that are both beautiful and
counter-intuitive
and materials that existed all along
that we just couldn't see
for what they really are
hey this portion of the video was
sponsored by lastpass and
they have sponsored a number of my
videos in the past which tells me two
things
number one many of you have signed up so
you don't have to remember your
passwords anymore or worry about getting
locked out of your accounts
and number two some of you have not yet
signed up
hence this reminder that your accounts
will be more secure and your brain
less cluttered when you put your
passwords on autopilot with lastpass
they give you unlimited password storage
free cross-device sync
and even password sharing if you ever
need to give someone else access to one
of your accounts
lastpass autofills your credentials on
mobile sites and apps for ios and
android
and it is so fast and easy when you open
an app or site lastpass fills in your
username and password in an instant
now real talk do you have important
accounts with the same password
i used to and it's not secure but
remembering a random string of
characters is not something i expect my
brain to do
have you had to reset one of your
passwords recently it's annoying and the
time you waste
will just accumulate over your lifetime
there are small steps you can take today
that will improve every day for the rest
of your life and getting a great
password manager
is one of those steps so click the link
below and start using lastpass today
i want to thank lastpass for sponsoring
this portion of the video and i want to
thank you for watching